oh
what is that please tell me you're
recording that
does that mean we're live it does what
up nerds welcome to another episode of
Gamespot after dark we're back we're
live again we were not live for a long
time and now we're live
yeah crazy how sometimes you can be not
live but then you can be live I feel
alive yeah I live alive we've got a new
studio so we're can you be quiet
[Laughter]
um we've got a new studio now so uh
we're making the most of it I'm joined
as always by Lucy James hi oh now I'm
allowed to talk yep wow speak one spoken
to
uh also joined by Michael P Heim the P
stands for Pino hey what to do baby and
we also joined by Max Blumenthal AKA Rin
harasaki what's up say my name right
thank you yeah I know
um who are you
Max is no view then oh you didn't enter
yourself Town that's what I meant oh no
everyone people don't need to know who I
am uh I am I'm the host tomorrow uh Max
is joining us this is your first time on
the podcast yes it is Max is joining us
for the first time on this podcast
because one
he works at GameStop
two he is probably
the biggest expert he's definitely on
our team for for The Elder breath of the
wild and um tears of the Kingdom but I
would say probably in the business I
would say I would say I would say we're
throwing the gauntlet down there's no
one in the video game journalism
industry that is as good at Zelda as Max
that's that's fast I bet on that I would
bet good money on that I already know
that's true
who wants it
come out my boy come on
I agree
yeah
um I mean I think folks may know about
the running dock of yeah that's not true
max is on oh wow okay John Luke find out
what episode that is we go
um there's a there's a running Google
Document for breath of the wild that Max
manages am I allowed to say that
publicly that's that's open source right
yeah is it are using the same one for
tears of the Kingdom no different one
okay because I've seen the tears of the
kingdom when I was like how is this this
long already yeah like the games this is
like pre-released if you've looked up
some exploits glitches or whatever for
breath of the wild Max probably found
that somehow straight up yeah Maxine is
community of Little Zelda weirdos we're
Big Macs we're big fans we're big fans
of Max Bloom with all over here yeah so
we're going to talk a little bit about
tears of the Kingdom with our expert and
then uh after we're done we're gonna
kick him out because he's outlived his
usefulness at that point get him out of
here um
so yeah uh tears of the Kingdom reviews
went up uh sounds like it's a good game
sounds like it's a good game yeah 10 out
of 10 gamespot.com
um doesn't mean it's perfect just means
it's essential you've got to play that
game
um you can read at length and watch the
video review on
um YouTube uh written by Steve and John
Luke on the edit Stephen yeah
um who put in a hell of a shift
completely again yeah
um yeah but uh man's got a family yeah
yeah for real babies man those last two
paragraphs of that review it was
beautiful right beautiful yeah yeah
it's amazing so um you've also played a
little bit too right I played a bunch of
it yeah I've been playing a lot of it um
I've been playing it I play I definitely
have been playing it different from you
I'm definitely thinking different from
Steve because like I've been trying to
play it slower yeah and not try and get
through as much as part I've got a good
grasp of the mechanics but also like
I've been it's wild because I messaged
you I was like what the hell is this all
about and you're like I don't know what
that is like and it was like near the
beginning of the game so like it's very
open in that you can just go and do
whatever you want and miss important
things like it took me a really like I
was maybe 10 hours into the game before
I realized I didn't have the camera
function in the Puro pad or whatever
it's called I was like oh [__] that's a
basic thing like you have to unlock that
via question
and eventually someone was like you need
to take a picture of this and I was like
what
and like I've done like loads of
missions in question adventuring by that
point so it's kind of very open wait do
you still have the chicest light yeah
it's called yeah pad now
it's just kind of a weird name yeah
[Music]
and I don't I don't I don't have the
same they can't use the Chica thing now
can they because after the last game I
guess I guess not yeah yeah I'm like 60
hours into the game already and I've
just started to almost 100 unlock the
entire map I guess we're map Towers oh
wow yeah so that's just how massive this
freaking is how many hours do you think
you've put in breath of the wild breath
of the wild yeah breath of the Wild
5000 probably
yeah I think he put in more time in
breath of the wild than I have in Final
Fantasy 14 yeah I don't think I put five
thousand dollars into anything yeah
because the the first time I had my
switch I think I had about 1200 hours
and then I got stolen no I hate to see
it homeboy uh Julio and the social team
back then they stole it wow
foreign
do you like it what do you think about
it it's amazing yeah it's amazing I've
never played a game like this before
um
I think I was talking to other people
about it too or like
the the abilities are so new and
specific that like you have to they
build the world in a specific way
because of the Ascend and the the time
reversal and all that so
I I've never played a game like like
yeah it's just there's really nothing
you can really explain about it you just
have to try it yourself and like you
know tomorrow everybody will be playing
it but does it unlock at 9pm tonight it
should be for West Coast yeah yeah
unless you're on Australia time then
you're up in like my switch is set to UK
does it unlock are you allowed to do
that are you allowed to say I don't know
if that works well I mean if I buy the
game on my UK switch yeah which is still
set to a UK that is hotter than you
might think yeah
um so do you find it overwhelming yeah
playing the game no yeah like just
opening it up I mean how overwhelming is
it with new powers and all the new stuff
you can do
um I got pretty used to it pretty quick
I can definitely see it building being
pretty bad for other people though like
casual players um I'm definitely like
whenever I like do any of my videos for
Gamespot I try to put myself in the
shoes of casual players because like
some of the stuff I'm trying to explain
is like just goes away over people's
heads
um so like thinking about that and
playing this game first I'm like some of
these abilities were like kind of
mind-boggling and like really confused
the crap out of some new players it's
easy to like I think the thing that I
kept finding was you train yourself to
play One games in a certain way and then
breath of the wild in in a certain way
so like it takes me I still do it I
forget that Ascend exists yeah and I'm
like climbing doing this like painful
climbing process and I'm like I could
have just hit two buttons and been all
the way up here I just spent 10 minutes
doing this and the amount of times that
keeps happening it's it's wild because
like you keep remembering that you've
got these abilities in scenarios where
you're like how am I going to do this
and then you try and do it in a way that
you know is manual and eventually you're
like oh I've got a power where I can
reverse time on this specific object and
it just like blows your mind in that
it's just very open
um yeah I think the um the difference
between plain before and after launch
because we had the experience of playing
before launch is that we don't have
social media to bounce off of and
there's gonna be some crazy stuff on
social media within next week or so that
we're gonna be like wow that's possible
um so like ways to get up a cliff would
be definitely something that we could
find yeah for sure Ralph was uh telling
me about a clip he saw where someone
made some kind of like giant stats then
and then there was a dong and yeah yeah
there's a who yeah I've seen I've seen
this is like a flamethrower Dawn oh yeah
yeah everyone's everyone's making people
so the other thing dungeons yeah that
was the big thing from the last one that
a lot of people were missing what are
they like now are they traditional are
they somewhere in between they're
somewhere in between so like if it's
like if you're thinking of like Ocarina
of Time or something like that
um it's more or less like an enclosed
space
um I think well I don't know if this is
semi-spoiler territory like one of
them's more enclosed and the other ones
are like more like open outside there's
no like specific walls to like keep it
in
um it's just part of the world which is
kind of interesting um it's not like a
separated off area so yeah um but people
be very happy about that because that's
like a legacy thing in Zelda and like
breath of the wild had those like Divine
beasts which is like they were cool yeah
um but yeah it's the same the color is
really boring too yeah and also like the
dungeons we have these kind of dungeons
but it's not a Zelda dungeon in the it's
not built around unlocking a new item or
ability or that kind of stuff you just
complete a dungeon and similarly it
means that like Steve mentions this in
his review but as you go further it's
not like it Stacks abilities to try and
test you they're very just like open you
you'll have the tools to do it
regardless right when you do it
um the other thing is like what what is
in breath of the Wild
that or like you were like I wish they
had done this
that they have now done like is it have
they like fixed anything that you're
like oh damn oh man I I remember I
there's like a list I had in my head of
like those kind of things yeah and I
just totally forgot them so I'm gonna
have to like recap as I talk here um
one of them well uh I guess glitch is
not really part of that yeah um
God God had to think about that yeah
because even like I see I'm not super
high level in combat or anything like
that but I can already see like crazy
applications of the abilities that you
have and Michael my thought was like is
this breaking it more or have they
managed to somehow like put these even
weirder abilities while also like
patching up the things that were kind of
wild about the original yes so um I
can't confirm a lot of stuff has been
patched I'm actually kind of theorizing
in my head on it how Nintendo approached
this because they must have been
watching us like 100 because there's
like really nice stuff I was like wait
no this definitely worked
yeah yeah so
um I'm kind of like uh interested in
what their responses I never will never
hear it obviously yeah but I'm just
interested in what they what they
thought about that um but there's
definitely been stuff that's patch 100
for sure yeah Nintendo's gathering
around the computer like hey Gamespot
just dropped into 11 things you didn't
know about bro I'm gonna kill it right
now like oh [__] yo it's Max again
um how do you people are in the chat
have asked um uh Jacob McCoy especially
says if people haven't played breath of
the Wild
is tears of the Kingdom a good starting
point or should they play breath of the
Wild
breath of the wild first in my opinion I
guess like
the tears of the king is like Evolution
100 it's not the same Vibe as breath of
the wild breath of the Wilds was like a
very calm relaxing open error game yeah
um lots of exploring and like just
taking in like the views and like the
the world
um tears of the Kingdom already just has
that set up and just piles a whole bunch
of [__] yeah so
um yeah I don't I don't I don't you can
play Tears of the Kingdom first
um you'll be a little bit confused on
the story yeah um but I I still
recommend doing breath of the wild first
at least a little bit you don't have to
beat the game but just like understand
like the the base world yeah it kind of
uh trains you on the basics of how the
world works and how you kind of move
around it and also like the flow of
gameplay in a much safer or like a a
more approachable environment yeah
because tears of the kingdom it jumps
straight in like it does not mess around
there's actually quite a lengthy like
setup sequence at the beginning with the
store for the story stuff but then once
you're there it's like it's very
different from the great Plateau where
it's like you very slowly get to grasps
with moving around and you know floating
using your glider and then figuring out
Towers this feels like it has an
equivalent like almost like a training
Quest yeah which is the first one which
is like go to all these points but
because of the way the world is set up
or it's like broken pieces and it's like
very like layered in that way
it's way harder to just do that Quest
because it took that was took me a while
because I was like how do I even get up
there yeah and you have to like start
thinking in like three dimensions almost
like you have to think about oh I can
jump down there float down there there
was one point where I was like trying to
get on a piece of floating like blend
and I was like
pushing the stick up to try and get him
like to move the centimeter as he's
falling stuff like that but I think yeah
I think you're right in that um breath
of wild feels like a good a better
starting point
um
for people who like
want to play the game how important or
how critical is the kind of fusing and
building stuff
some people like they just it doesn't
work for them like their brains can't
work in that way and it's like I don't
know how to solve this thing is there
options for them yeah I think
um almost maybe not
um a lot of the game really forces that
stuff
um I think that they made it lenient
enough so that you can like make really
basic stuff and still be okay to like
complete the things but like
the crazier the better honestly yes
that's what they're really pushing for
like they really want you to use all the
tools so yeah because um one of the
things like when I watch Tears of the
Kingdom gameplay one of the things I
don't know if I have the patience to
build in the intricate ways that I think
yeah the game allows you to and I you
know that's that's one of the one of the
great things about the game I think it's
like you can be as creative as you want
with it but I look at that I'm like damn
man I don't know if I got this yeah so
how have you all found the like the
threshold in which like something like I
can just put together this piece of [__]
rafting it'll be good enough to get
where I want to go you can do the basics
I think like
as a kind of prospect the moment to
moment can be quite exhausting or like
not frustrating but like there's certain
kinds of people who losing a single you
out but damn wow
the reason I say is because I'm the same
where I think I'm like we are very
similar in that yeah they need when I
play something or do something I want to
feel a sense of like moment forward
momentum completion a story a story and
something like that and this is a game
where like basic kind of progression is
gated behind like puzzles that require a
lot of time attention and almost like
creative thinking yeah it's like in the
most games you'll be like oh here's a
massive Gap it'll be like oh just jump
or like oh I can't get there until this
is like I need to find these pieces
you know put it together and then get
across this thing and it's like that
isn't the main quest that is just you
trying to get to the main quest right so
people like us like I I definitely went
into it at times when I was like
playing it where I wasn't in the right
mindset or the frame of kind of like
frame of mind and
I got a little bit frustrated because I
was trying to make progress in the game
and they're kind of like forcing my way
forward but the game is built for you to
to almost like force you to pay play
slower
don't worry about this it's that same
kind of I think that like for you and
for me to a degree as well like there's
a high chance of bouncing off okay it's
the kind of like where it's like you
have to work for the fun or yeah but I
want to be involved in the conversation
yeah it's one of those things where like
the process is the fun
and
it also doesn't make a song and dance
about what you get out of it like when
you finish something it's not like wow
you've got this amazing new thing here
it is it's just like all right good yeah
Clorox seeds again yes
you collect 10 of them and you're like
okay this this is the same and like what
did they give us last time golden poo or
something it's always golden poop
golden poop yeah oh [__] yeah because it
wasn't done rake it the first person to
get them all I don't know if I want to
say he was one of the firsts
yeah yeah please correct them even I
didn't get them all so in five thousand
hours yeah I started I was like this is
not it's too much no definitely not
actually talking about coral she can
strap a rocket onto them now and oh wow
you can do in this game
Vendetta against them from the last game
how much are y'all allowed to talk about
story content if at all even if I was
allowed to oh no yeah okay
yourself yeah I think the one of the
most attractive Paul event is the Catch
22 for people like Lucy and me where
it's like I mean I was gonna play anyway
but like now more than ever the actual
story is important yes like because
obviously
I'm not gonna say what but you learn
like they need to I would say revise
Hyrule Historia after this yes like
because there's some like wild stuff in
there that Zelda fans are getting
insight into that's fascinating like and
I've been playing Zelda for years and I
was like it's been a long time since
I've been interested in the story of
Zelda like the intricacies of
relationships and how we got to here and
there and that kind of stuff so that's
that's the tricky part of it because
it's such a good story and it's such a
good like filled with good characters
and like Zelda as a character is both
more present also not as present yeah
there's like a weird thing happening in
that game with that with that character
and it's just like fascinating to see
where it's like the actual format and
the structure of the story is really
interesting in a way I haven't seen
Nintendo do before like it's it's
Nintendo known for telling stories in a
very simple way or not at all this is a
kind of complicated story that's got
like depth and emotional resonance told
in a unexpected way where it's layered
and fractured and you have to put the
pieces together and it's really
interesting to see but you have to go
through that the difficult gameplay
stuff to to get to that which is kind of
wild it's non-sequential like breath of
the wild because anybody can be doing it
in any order yeah exactly
um performance issues any how has your
experience been
um so I I did duplicate Steve Watts
situation with [__] Rico Village yeah it
was raining and it was lagging a bit
um
building at all like fusing stuff
together and like making a machine and
then just like putting it out into the
world like if it fights an enemy that
thing the frame rate's gonna drop to
like 10 minutes it gets really bad yeah
that was unfortunate because I was
really looking forward to that stuff and
I was like oh I got this really cool
Contraption I like you know set it out
to go attack a base and it was like 15
FPS for like a second yeah yeah so when
you're playing on the OLED switch I have
a day one regular switch oh no yes no
yeah I don't yeah I mean Nintendo you
have to pretty much play on an OLED yeah
I mean this is like also post patch too
which is like supposedly it's
performance boost but I haven't seen any
difference
um
it's just unfortunate because you know
breath of the wild had the same problems
and it seems to kind of persist here
it's just like the more stuff that is
happening it's not it's not like the
more stuff but it's also like what it's
doing too so if it's like if it's
multiple turrets looking for things or
if it's multiple like fire effects
happening like those things really add
up for sure I think like that is
definitely true and I've had some of
that myself
um but I never felt like it was ruining
the experience for me yeah like it
always feels very playable they are just
it's kind of like you you know when
you're building something as you're
building it you're like I'm about to I'm
about to screw these frames because that
is you can tell like this is getting
elaborate it's crazy and something like
the switch is probably gonna have
struggles with handling it and that's
exactly what happens yeah and like I'm
not building crazy Contraptions but if
you are that kind of person you should
probably factor in the fact that it's
going to be wild and there's not I think
it's similar on
um docked as well as um uh handheld
supposedly it's better on handheld
because it's lower resolution yeah but
um yeah it's it's either way it's pretty
bad I mean yeah switch is so old by now
yeah six years man yeah lifetime yeah
but yeah it's it's a fantastic game and
I feel like you can already tell that
it's very open-ended to the point where
in the same way the breath of the wild
was like we're going to be finding stuff
like for years
for years 100 yeah yeah so max how many
things do you think you don't know
y'all better get ready for some content
bro well my doc already for like the
things I found is already like 80 things
long and then whoa yeah and that's just
small tiny thing so there's gonna be
plenty more yay so yeah make sure you
subscribe to youtube.com to see all of
that stuff Max is going to be there
um you're you're a full-time Zelda
content creator for us basically yeah
unfortunately yeah it's all said
unfortunate
but yeah Max thank you for joining us
we'll free you I know you're very busy
you've got to see all the stuff to do
okay
John Luke back in here yeah we'll get
John Luke back in here
um Peace Out Max give Max a follow on
Twitter yeah
uh Rin harasaki spell it
right in the mic 5 AK
yeah you can find him uh while we're
waiting for John Luke to sub in what you
guys what's your text on are you gonna
play it no that's right it's uh I don't
know if I'm gonna play it like right now
right now because I there are still
games that I need to play that I want to
finish even on on switch and I don't
want to I don't want this to be one of
those games where I put in maybe like 10
hours and then put it down for a week
and then come back to it be like damn I
don't know what the hell is going on so
I guess I'm never gonna get back to it
because this happened so many times to
me and I'm gonna talk about a game that
I kind of did that too a little later on
but
um it's it's hard because like I do want
to be part of the conversations that are
happening right now um and that's that's
exciting that was like one of the most
exciting things about breath of the wild
and I remember being in the office and
you know watching Peter at his desk like
oh [__] yo you found something that I
didn't know even existed in this game
and it was just that constant feedback
of finding something someone else did
and getting something from them uh so I
want to be in on that I want to know
what the conversations are but that
stuff takes time man like this game is
huge and like like you all were saying
some of that stuff is like you could
probably sit down and play for five
hours and like really get into the weeds
of the mechanics of this game and
exploring that world and then not
necessarily get to like the the thing
the quest that you're looking for maybe
you don't feel like you've made progress
and like that that's that's dope and I
think that's a that's a it's a unique
approach to uh games and progress but
again that requires patience Yeah by you
Lucy I'm gonna play it I'm going to my
friend's house at the weekend and we're
gonna do a pajama party and we're all
gonna play WoW
oh that's cute
no I want to play I just
I just you know part of the conversation
um part of if I don't play it now as
soon as June rolls around and Diablo and
Final Fantasy comes around I'm you know
that's my yeah I will I will drop it and
I'll move on and if so if I don't play
it now I'm I probably won't revisit it
because yeah you got like baldi's game
stuff too so yeah I know oh yeah
hi have you heard of Tears of the
Kingdom uh what's that yeah
of course uh edit the video review check
out on youtube.com having seen so much
of it now are you in excited to play it
oh absolutely yeah I've been like I'm
like counting down I I ordered a
physical copy
um because I bought I've bought all the
Zelda games on switch physically so
it'll arrive tomorrow and then I was
like oh but it comes out tonight
digitally at nine what if I buy it again
so what I'm thinking but I've actually
come up with a good workaround because
Georgia was like oh I kind of want to
play it this time because she's also
going to that she is also going to that
slumber party so I was like okay well I
could buy digitally tonight and I could
just let her use my physical tomorrow
I came up with feel too bad about buying
the game twice uh yeah I'm extremely
excited I'm also someone who never beat
breath of the wild
um and I've always meant to go back to
it
and so so I'm not gonna have that issue
that you guys were talking about where
like because I know how that game plays
but I am there is a part of me that
still does want to eventually go back to
playing breath of the wild and I'm I'm
so curious how all how that will feel
like if it'll if it'll play and I'll be
like oh I can't do this or I can't build
that like like is the game gonna feel
um like obsolete but I I don't know if
it will I think so you know yeah because
I think the vibe of that game at least
feels the vibe is different and also
like the tools you have at your
disposals are very different which means
the puzzles are built very differently
um but yeah I think they're very
complementary to each other and tears of
the kingdom is definitely built upon the
foundations of it when you're running
around Hyrule again you'll be like I
remember this right um but it does have
that new dimension where you go into the
sky and there's like stuff up there you
can do a bit of but they feel like two
very different
but similarly kind of connected games
and the world is like super weird as
well like the stuff has happened where
it's like fractured the world and it's
like a a weird substance that is
everywhere corrupting things and it does
have its own like unique new spin on
that same world
um so I think you could they're
complementary to each other yeah which
is good did you uh did you feel like you
got to a point where you can pick it
back up and be like Oh I'm just gonna go
fight Ganon now and finish the game I I
didn't actually finish all of the Divine
beasts so but I guess technically you
could just go and fight Ganon whatever
you want right it's like I probably
could go in and finish Cannon I think
there were like a couple spots on the
map that I never explored that okay I
would kind of like to go back and do but
I guess I'll experience them in tears so
it'll be kind of interesting to see it
reverse almost it's like the end I mean
you get far long enough the end is
pretty easy I would say that's what I've
heard yeah again it's not that hard it's
like exciting and it has like it's like
a really great spectacle but in terms of
difficulty like you're not going to have
to bang your head against the wall it's
actually more of a challenge if you
don't do all the Divine beats right it's
not the whole thing you know just kind
of cool
um also I I don't think he mentioned it
but I did ask Max is it possible to go
and beat
tears of the Kingdom at the very
beginning
said today uh it was an article I think
on IGN where it's like you can yeah but
don't well Max specifically said well
Max said you can but he said it is
extremely difficult he's like I don't
think I can do it wow like Max's gonna
do it none of y'all can do it I'm sure
someone will yeah like within a day like
five hours
someone's already done it by the time
yeah this podcast is finished with a
bloody you know joy-con with drift you
know yeah but it sounds like it's a
harder challenge which is cool that's
neat yeah I mean you do that once you've
mastered every other aspect of the game
right yeah uh it's the biggest game
of one of the biggest games of the year
so far so I think like and it's also a
game where it's going to be in
conversations for a really long time
yeah definitely at the end yeah so yeah
it's not going away it's not going away
and like a lot of people are like I wish
I could play this now I think like
you if you waited you'd still be part of
a conversation it might not be like the
one that's happening now yeah this game
is so like big and complex that
something will be going on around this
game for years to come you could go back
and play breath of the wild right now
and still have like a great time like
yeah yeah
um yeah this is older tears of the
Kingdom you'll probably hear about it a
lot more going forward but we've got the
review up on gamespot.com and also on
YouTube please go check it out 10 out of
10. 10. um which means essential 10 of
them things on The Game Spot scale yeah
um Steve Watts Steve Watts a banger yeah
um
John look what else have you been doing
oh that's a good question what have I
been doing
um building this studio you know what it
is sure I'm filming the studio testing
it out uh getting getting it all working
um
just watched I just keep watching anime
but I feel like I don't know
I finished your boy Kong Ming which was
just delightful okay and and wholesome
very good
um I I first off I want to point out how
like
incredible of a localization for the
name is because I think like the
original Japanese basically translates
to like party person Kong Ming like he's
like a party animal but like changing it
to ya boy Kong Ming like it absolutely
evokes captures the body it captures the
vibe yeah uh perfectly
um yeah I don't know that's just the
whole thing anime I recommend yeah so
you have to get high dive though that's
like the whole thing
there are so many good anime high dives
but you have to get high dive listen I
can't we talk all kinds of [__] about
the Crunchyroll app at least I can
screen mirror and use airplay to my
smart TV first world prompts for sure I
know I know what it is but High Dive at
least please let let me AirPlay to my TV
dog I pay for your subscription who's
behind that high dive no idea
no idea please it must be owned by some
big company yeah because like how do you
how are you getting
oh yeah are they in the Bay Area
are they a block over like crunchyroller
why did I die okay
I'll give High Dive one credit which is
that they do uh let you uh
simultaneously use the same account uh
at the same time
no no no no they say it oh okay like
like a state thing like they say like
hey you know you can you can use it
twice for like you know I think like
Hulu kicks you out I don't think
Crunchyroll doesn't Netflix is very
uptight about that [__] exactly
depending on which tier you have because
uh all of my family are on my Netflix
and so I know that it does at least
before yeah well no it's the reason that
my Netflix uh anime anime Avatar is the
boss baby because I'm the youngest in
the family and yeah it's your account
everyone nice bloody Netflix yeah it's
cheaper in the US
there's also like so many different
tiers of that at this point like yeah
I have the 4K one because that has the
different profiles yeah but I've already
I've already told them as soon as the
password sharing stuff goes into effect
you're out on your ass yeah yeah get a
grip Uncle Ken build your own piles
what that's a uh that's a succession
reference remember he tells them to
build their own powers
but that's from like Season Two Season
three actually season three
I'm saying this because I've watched two
seasons in two days of succession that's
a lot of it's crazy a lot of succession
bro I've been like working and watching
at the same time because my brain is on
overdrive currently sure it's like wild
High Dive is an independent anime
streaming company based out of Houston
Texas okay okay being in 2017. and the
Cowboys are giving us the good anime
yeah there's this short amount we've uh
acquired the rights to over 500 series
movies and overs all right um
the track cleared
um and gives you a price that won't make
your wallet all right all right all
right interesting it is it is quite
cheap was it like five bucks it's like
five bucks a month yeah and it looks
like they've got a lot of series here
that are good that's the thing they have
really good stuff the app is just ass
yes
I mean and like if you wanna
kick it on the same level as one of
these other streaming services you can't
have the experience user experience to
be [__] yeah
um so yeah I think you've got a lot of
pieces in place yeah we say that but
like even like the most high profile
streaming service FUNimation is straight
booty still yeah well they stop
supporting it I think now because why
technically yeah it's just all
Crunchyroll culturally they just sucks
man anime is so hard to get please just
give me I want it just give it to me
please hey you just don't uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
yet but very good that's definitely one
of them and like you be John Luke has
told me about akibo made War so many
times at this point please watch it yeah
I'm kind of sad that I haven't spent the
time to uh watch it but I know you'll
love it yeah yeah there wasn't there's
an anime I've been cut I started monster
that is good I saw a monster yeah yeah
yeah that's like Kurt yeah I texted her
one on Netflix it's on Netflix on
Netflix not all of itself
that's just like 57 episodes he said it
wasn't all on Netflix
seven I'm gonna add it to my list
they're like hella episodes like that
[__] as long as maybe they added the
rest finally I don't know but that's
what Curry was talking about the monster
is really really good apparently it's
high dive is AMC oh that explains a lot
yeah newest addition to AMC's Network
portfolio Liars independent my ass so
what is it Monster dude I need to call
it Monster no Nicole Kidman what's her
name oh yeah that's Nicole Kidman I need
her I need her to play at the front of
every anime episode I watch now and I
think the anime version of Nicole Kidman
we come to this place
um yeah uh monster is really good I I
remember back in the day when it first
came out it was like that and death note
was the thing yeah and they were like
dark [__] at the same time yeah and it
was like the dark era yeah it it has a
lot of Death Note Vibes and maybe that's
derivative but I do get the the same
feelings can you imagine if they had
used monster as the main theme oh yeah
Nicki Minaj's monster yes yes
specifically just Nicki Minaj
I'm sure that's out there somewhere oh
someone's AMV yeah
to my and YouTube playlist I've been uh
building because that's what a
[__] wants to do oh my God
that's that's wild
um but yeah monsters monsters crazy no
no no that's just random you can do it
that's that's all yeah you've got an
adobe put it on I'll make it yeah yeah
make it and put it on YouTube okay
so you know how we got a bunch of series
and like that's that's the thing for
game Squad we have a bunch of great
shows
a new series where he just makes amv's
and people get to watch that we can't
monetize at all we use like open source
music okay music yeah yeah oh yeah
Lincoln Park type beat yeah yeah I I
would if I got paid to do that oh that'd
be Evanescence type beat God damn wow
there are old uh uh what was it called
uh audio network was our yeah they had
some wild stuff I remember finding that
was one it was Star Wars one there was
Space Monkey obviously
um the the classic Giant Bomb uh
lockdown comes from oh lockdown as well
uh you know all all of the Bake Off
music comes from audio Network oh no way
I'm Kevin McLeod oh okay Kevin McLeod is
the the goat I can never find it again
but I remember I remember finding one
that was just clearly like a ripoff of
Poker Face yeah and being like obsessed
with it for a while yes on audio Network
it was the um the Eminem one too yes
there was an Eminem one oh yeah oh my
God hey shoot me the link I want to hear
this
oh what a place very briefly we had oh
there's fettuccine we switched over to a
different audio we've like swapped like
for three or three now over but the
middle one we had I forget what it was
called No a universal APM APM was the
one we had that was great because they
had all the music from the first three
seasons of SpongeBob
I
had to incredible that's what's up yes
anyway that was about it I did I haven't
started it yet and I probably won't
because tears of the Kingdom but I did
buy on sale
uh wanted Dead okay
fair I had been I've heard about it for
a while and I was like yeah it seems
like a a me type thing you know like me
and me and benjenko were the the weirdo
like yeah absolutely yeah uh so sick
that's good that's good yeah okay so I
bought that and I was like all right I
gotta check this out um probably I'll
probably wait till after this Fool's
playing wants it dead instead of Tears
of the Kingdom damn Kurt Kurt talk about
that on his video lovely extremely good
video um and then the game went on sale
the day later or that's no that same
yeah there's a wild amount of things
coincidences
should we talk about what it was related
are a bit spicy sure
spicy with it but yeah
but that went up like a day or two
before but we didn't no because it
didn't boiling
boiling all that until that day and then
and then it turned out that like that's
the day that could I put up yeah Chris
put up this and then your game uh
changed there review rubric
um the game went on sale
he made a whole thread about the amount
of times that's happened to him uh he's
manifesting there is he made a video
about uh why Nintendo should make
another uh Wii Sports and then like a
month later they announced uh the
Nintendo switch Sports he made a video
about
um why pikmin's great and then they
announced like Pikmin for like a couple
weeks later okay can you make a video
about me getting an attempt getting on
green cards
oh that's cute
hurry up yes
um yeah uh you should watch that video
it's great yeah
cut Locker or as I call it
say it say it or say it the squirt
Locker
um squirt lock damn Square Locker barely
I don't know well because he said it to
us we were like oh we're gonna no no
because Lisa would go into shoes
that's kind of that's kind of fun
oh yes squirt Locker is great spit on is
great too
um my show no HUD or as I like to call
it no head oh so what go ahead
we need to send all these back to the
drawing board are these Brands safe
uh home what you've been up to
these are my confessions I got a
confession yep and I'm not proud of this
actually I'm going to probably
disappoint uh half the people who uh
follow me for weeb [__] you never
actually played octopath traveler too no
I die of video evidence
you've been lying this whole time
it's green oh my God I have finished
octopath traveler too hold on what
sandwich challenge says there's a
Michael Hyman joke somewhere oh
I haven't heard that one before y'all
[__] uh it's that's actually a
pretty good one I didn't get that a lot
I think the worst one that I I mean has
nothing to do with my name but he's in
elementary school they call me Hunchback
of Notre Dame because I had really bad
posture and I was like taller than
everyone oh so I have really bad posture
they call me that and kind of hurt my
feelings but
I jumped him and told stole their
Pokemon cards good
so my confession yeah is that
um
damn I'm kind of nervous actually I
never finished with Xenoblade Chronicles
three
we never finished the game so as last
year is my game of the year and I also
said that it is easily in my top five
games of all time having not finished it
and I never finished it my man because
well here's the thing you get there's a
certain chapter in the game it's like
about I would say 60 70 of the way
through that chapter is chapter five
everyone if you played Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 you know what chapter five
means and I made it to that point
because it feels like an apex of that
story it feels like a there's a climax
haha the that things there are a lot of
things that get resolved in after that
chapter that feel like a breath of fresh
air like something changes in that world
right and you kind of like oh there's
it's like a new beginning for the
characters and for that story and then
so I I put 75 hours into the game to get
past chapter five and after that I was
like you know what I'm gonna take a real
quick breather I'll get back to this uh
because I want to like let this moment
kind of rest let me think about it let
it simmer in my brain because it was
kind of it was if you you've played
Xenoblade Chronicles 3 it's a very
emotional it's heavy it feels like a
very heavy moment in the game it's a lot
to process so in that moment I was like
okay I'm gonna chill for a minute and
then get back to the game and I did the
thing that you do sometimes is that you
just never get back to it
and I think part of me you had like
convinced myself that it did finish the
game and that was actually all there was
to it
um but there's so much wait I was gonna
say chapter five of how many I think
seven and yeah seven and then a final
chapter you can correct me if I'm wrong
I don't know because uh people in the
chat calling you phony a fraud it's a
fraud it's a fraud it's a fraud
[__] y'all I love y'all but um so I went
back to it and the thing so here's
here's the other part too is that I've
always wanted to go back to it because I
love it very dearly and there was a
thing of being hesitant to get back to
it because I don't want to be
emotionally overwhelmed yeah like when I
hear the Town music play again when I
hear those characters speak again it's
it's it's just a lot to me and I I love
them I miss them dearly and they're
right there there's more there's more to
that game that I haven't even seen yet
so
um I need to I I booted it back up and
just said you know what I'm gonna bite
the bullet I'm gonna like get my feet
wet get back into it do side quests to
ease myself to that combat system
because that [__] is kind of complicated
uh you got to a certain point where you
can sort of automate oh man yeah
automate the things that characters do
because it's not a turn-based RPG you
can kind of just set your characters and
just let them go uh if you want to play
that way and press a bunch of buttons I
don't know the [__] they do but I went
back into it and I've been easing myself
into it and you expect another thread if
you follow me on Twitter I have like a
50 tweet thread of my playthroughs you
know play Chronicles 3 and my last one
of it was like screencap from chapter
five saying like holy [__] I have a lot
of feelings and uh yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna do it again when carry on uh and
trust me I will finish it this year it
will be my so another the impetus for
this is because the future redeemed DLC
came out last month or a couple weeks
ago and a bunch of my friends on Discord
have been talking about it and I'm I'm
like ah I'm gonna have to mute y'all for
this one don't say anything because I
know that they want to talk about it but
I'm just like uh I know my friends at
acts of the blood God wants to do a
spoiler cast I know Jake wants to do a
spoiler spoiler cast still
but I need to I need to get back to it
and everything I've heard about the
future redeemed DLC everyone's just like
yo this [__] is amazing this is Game of
the Year quality stuff uh compact into
like a 20 or 30 hour RPG so the idea of
a condensed Xenoblade story is extremely
attractive to me and I want to get to it
and uh I haven't played I haven't
finished one I barely played two so I
don't know if it's gonna hit as hard
because the whole point of that DLC is
that they all Loop uh together along
with three and some some weird and wacky
ways but I am so that's that's one one
of the reasons why I was hesitant to
jump into tears of the Kingdom now yeah
is because I need to do myself redeem
yourself I need to yeah the future needs
to be redeemed uh my own future needs to
be redeemed but um yeah Chronicles three
man like and not to get too like over
emotional or overreactive about it but
the the themes of Xenoblade Chronicles 3
are heavy to me in particular
um so like knowing when your time's up
how to deal with the the idea of
of like death and health and uh
surviving and [__] like that it's just
it's just a lot for me sometimes I'm not
necessarily in the right headspace or
like what we were talking about earlier
but in this in this regard it's like I
don't know if I want to overwhelm myself
emotionally quite yet because it's yeah
but I did a couple quests I'm like going
back to it from because I've played a
bunch of RPGs since then and when I've
done I did some of the hero quests which
are these bespoke side quests that give
you more about characters in particular
and just the cutscenes uh what were you
watching some of those or seeing those
cut scenes again in the style in which
characters talk to each other dialogue
wise this like Xenoblade Chronicles 3 is
levels above most other games like I'm
gonna say that [__] straight up like the
natural way that they talk to each other
the mannerisms it just flows like
they're having human conversations which
uh is something I kind of wish like
octopath traveler 2 had a little bit
more of
but Xenoblade is extremely well written
well voice well voiced and just paced in
such a such a natural way but still
impressive man I got 75 hours 80 hours
at this point it'll be another 80 hours
bro you know what I'm saying so uh
that's that's what my life's gonna be
for the next for the foreseeable future
that's another game that really squeezes
a lot of power out of the switch despite
it no oh yeah and yeah yeah it's it I
just I talked about finishing Pokemon
Scarlet Violet a couple weeks ago when I
was on and the comparison was like the
[__] night and date and like thinking
about tears in the kingdom and how
impressive it is to like hey here's
breath of the wild also there's a whole
bunch of stuff in the sky that you can
explore and all that and how seamless
even though we're talking about like the
frame rate issues and the performance
issues the still uh impressive that that
thing can even exist on the switch and
playing zero play Chronicles three like
everything that world is still very very
beautiful yeah so but yeah that's uh
you know what I'm gonna be up to for the
next couple weeks
um but yeah there's also something oh
Hawkeye star rail I don't have anything
to do to say if you want to hear my
thoughts about Hawkeye star Rail and all
the the hot anime boys and anime girls
that I have pulled
okay
[Music]
I'm a honky you know what I'm saying I'm
straight stage straight up I'm a honky
wow that's what we call it that's what
we call a Hawkeye star out players relax
yeah we out here uh nothing necessarily
new to say compared to what I did last
week but I just been playing a [__] ton
more of that cool game great game Lucy
I've been playing Humanity uh from is it
that DHA and um
published by enhance he also published
uh Tetris effect so it is that really
cool game I think it was in the February
showcase uh the station one it's also
got a psbr2
integration uh I haven't finished it I'm
only like a couple hours in or so but
like it's a really cool puzzle game that
is most similar I guess in comparison's
sake to lemmings just hundreds of people
and you are a dog and you are leading
these people into the light oh and it's
really great like because as well the
thing that gets me is that in Lemmings
you know say there are 30 Lemmings you
have to save 25 of them to beat the
level with Humanity the you have to lead
them through these through you have to
make the pathways to lead them through
the levels but if they fall off it's
fine and they kind of encourage you to
experiment and so the only ones that you
have to save are Goldies which are kind
of like
the big tall gold people in the levels
and there's usually one or two
it's I don't know it's just like a
really
straight like simple to start but gets
increasingly complex really beautiful
music really cool Vibes I was talking
about it on FPS and I said it's a very
cool Vibes based game yeah and genuinely
like I'm not that far enough in there's
a lot of user created content like
there's a map editor and all that stuff
I don't have psvr too uh because I get
motion sick
um how'd that work in VR I don't know I
uh I assume well you because you kind of
look down on the levels and you can zoom
in and out so I wonder if it's more like
an astrobot Rescue Mission okay yeah
perspective yeah okay yeah that makes
sense I mean you feel like a god yeah
and then you're like a little dog you're
playing this dog a new dog god uh well
dog has gone backwards so
you think
um it's great and it's coming to PS plus
so I guess like if you have that I would
definitely I'd recommend buying it but
like that also just if you have PS plus
give it a go did you ever do you ever
play Echo Chrome no yeah oh okay again
uh similar type well I mean not similar
concept but I mean the MC Escher like
leading a manipulating though the way
the environment looks to lead a an
automated like figure or a character
Echo Chrome yeah there's two of them PSV
that was I think it was I think it was
originally a PSP game but I play on PS3
yeah it came back in the day it was like
black and white yeah okay yeah I
remember that now yeah yeah yeah
oh Japan Studio it's very hard to find
in our access now I don't know if it's
on I don't think it's on the PlayStation
I think it might be LPS there's no
PlayStation store I think that'd be a
great mobile if it's a mobile game oh
yeah if they would like Port that to
phones oh yep echo echo Chrome it's on
PS4 PS5 now Echo Chrome is beautiful
wonderful music I like chill just
kidding ah you hate to see it no the
story uh find the game through illicit
means if you know what I'm saying
echochrome is a classic you know I'm
saying Japan Studio they also did crappy
Rush right yeah yeah yeah a lot of
Gravity Rush three
I'm watching Queen Charlotte the Bridget
and spin-off which is it's fine it kind
of Queen Charlotte
hey you said the Bridgerton yeah there's
a bridgeton's been awful about the queen
and like it kind of does this bridgen
thing where it's good there's some like
good romance good chemistry but then
they'll just throw some like mad
problematic [__] in there and uh I was
talking about it with Andrew gold Bob
and I was like
um I mean it's about the British money I
was about to say yeah is it problematic
like the show doesn't tackle the topic
well or problematic as in like I mean
these characters are being problematic
and that's coming to the point without
going into too many details there's like
a character in there who is a young
woman who is married to this old guy and
it was clearly like this kind of a
ranged marriage and uh kind of makes
light of the fact that she is stuck in
that relationship and everything that
entails yeah and they make a joke of it
and it's like
but
[Music]
um those characters but anyway it's like
and then in episode four
take such a turn that Andrew told me
about it is the villain May he's the
demon Headmaster I was watching it and
then it's just about you know Queen
Charlotte and King George
and then a character comes in who's
basically
just an evil guy but he's like comic
book evil and I was just like I don't
really understand what what this guy's
coming in so apparently episodes four
and five not so good six manages to
redeem it a little bit uh so maybe I'll
finish that tonight tomorrow and then
we'll see but that's that's me it's been
a pretty low-key week I did a lot of
socializing at the weekend so damn damn
yeah look at me I'm showing off time I
was I was with you like too sure
three days three days yeah I was with
you all the time time except for the
Friday night so shut up
[Laughter]
um I've been playing obviously Taylor's
Kingdom good game I've been playing
Resident Evil 4 remake still because as
I explained like we went we went back to
London when it basically came out so
um I kind of fell behind I guess or just
didn't play very much and then the other
day last weekend I can't remember what
day it was uh it might have been Sunday
actually you're playing Jesus Kingdom on
Sunday yeah but that day before we came
back sessions yeah before we came over
it was like I woke up in the morning
early and played like six hours seven
hours of resume nice
um like just you know so I'm like in the
final stretch of the game yeah where are
you at that Salazar boss fight is ass
everyone seems to have trouble I did not
have a problem
I had no problem I I did not like that
boss fight there was something about it
that just like really messed me up I was
like I have trouble with it or did you
just not like it
um I did not like it like I did have a
little like it took me a few tries but
it was like really cheap where it was
like oh the one hit kill yeah one hit
kills and it'll be like oh you're hiding
behind a pillar and then some of that
weird ink [__] you would get through
somehow and I was like I'm hiding behind
the pillar I just blocked a [__] ton of
it and now one like splash of it gets
through and also like it's he's very far
away yeah and the way you do damage is
hit like a small part of him in the
middle his head so yeah so it's just
like did you bring a gold neck with you
huh did you bring a golden egg without
no no no I I did it with a pistol do you
know about that the Golden Age no what
was it you can you can throw a golden
egg at him and then it just you just
shoot him like twice and he dies yes I'm
not doing that there's chicken I also
shot him with a handgun yeah I did
handgun
it was fun I I use the the rifle which
is fun right I like the uh the rifle a
lot I use that for everything because
it's just like one shot yeah headshots
and it just rips everything yeah and
when they and when they mutate if you
shoot them in the right spot it kills
them instantly as well I'm curious what
you think of the
the last section of the game because
it's probably the most like dramatically
different yeah so you go away to like
the
the offshore kind of area yeah yeah the
island yeah the island yeah so that's
where I just got to cool yeah um I like
I like the way they they changed it up
yeah